want to work for Goldman Sachs you might
end up here this is a typical floor to
Goldman building it could be anywhere
until you look out the window
Salt Lake City is really the beneficiary
of a macro strategy within the firm to
move more of our jobs from traditional
hubs like New York London Hong Kong
Tokyo so much so that this is Goldman's
fastest-growing office five years ago
Goldman had fewer than 500 people here
today it's 1,500 and Counting bigger
than Chicago Frankfurt or Tokyo and by
the end of the year bigger than Hong
Kong I'm just gonna get one of these
Eric Alok is a 26 year old from
Albuquerque have a good day ed Goldman
not been in Salt Lake City she wouldn't
be working here as an Operations
associate when I was in college I didn't
think that this is where he would end up
they said that they were looking to
really develop the office and to grow I
would love to stay in Salt Lake for the
remainder of my career with Goldman I
mean if they asked me to move I would
consider but if I have the choice I
would want to stay in solving it's a
very young dynamic labor force and one
of the first things that strikes people
when they meet candidates here in the
interview candidates here is the level
of maturity of the people a large
composition of this office is made up
from people that were born and raised in
the state and many of those people spent
two years on a mission or somewhere
having a missionary experience around
the world an important part of the value
proposition of this office along with
talent and business resiliency has cost
these are tough times for banks the
economy stuck in first gear and
regulation is stifling business Golden
has slashed almost six billion dollars
of expenses since the financial crisis
in part by shifting resources to
Bangalore Singapore Dallas and Salt Lake
City
Rick Skidmore didn't start here he
transferred to Goldman's Utah office for
a simple reason
quality of life was in the New York City
office for 13 years and then was given
the opportunity to move to the Salt Lake
City office to start and run the
investment research division I have an
opportunity to be at my kids soccer
games for example or home for dinner
with the family where that wasn't quite
the opportunity when I worked in the New
York City office we're starting to
attract people globally our biggest
challenge has been growing from 300
people to over 1,500 people and making
sure that all of these new people that
are joining the firm are acculturated in
the right way when you're in the office
they think it's Goldman culture no
matter where in the world you are would
you trade New York for Salt Lake City
Utah is hardly a hotbed of Investment
Banking but it's cheap smart and safe
and that's good enough for Goldman Sachs
Eric Schatz Kerr Bloomberg Salt Lake
City